when you said uh uh Roe v Wade okay now
I'm telling you and you said you think
this is gonna happen no I know it's done
it's over it's this and it's like what
is this guy talking about it was
discouraging to a lot of people and then
boom it happens what's it because in
your mind you're sitting there saying
these three seats presidents come and go
but these three seats you know six to
three or five to four this stays for 20
30 years right when you made a comment
like that about Roe v Wade and then
right before midterms I don't know what
the timeline was six weeks before
midterms or whatever it was when they
you know made the whole thing you know
last June yeah and it was supposed to be
what a red wave and it ended up not
being a red way because America's like
listen man I would have been a red wave
but this thing that you guys did
probably not some on the left and the
right it's not like it's just the left
issue you know both sides what made you
be so confident at the time to say I
think this is going to happen well you
know I've I've covered the intersection
of Law and politics for for my my entire
career and you know abortion has been
the most contentious issue between and
frankly it is between left and right in
this country and you know you have to go
back to
um the 2016 campaign and remember Donald
Trump as a private citizen was open
about being pro pro-choice in favor of
abortion rights so when he's running for
the Republican nomination he had to
convince the Evangelical community in
particular that he was trustworthy on
their issues and so when he
um
ran for president he essentially
outsourced the issue of judicial
confirmations to a guy named Leonard Leo
in the federal society and they made a
list of the judges that they were the
the president that if Trump won he was
going to appoint to the Supreme Court
and those judges were all clearly
identified with the um anti-roe v Wade
position and this was an extremely
effective thing that Trump did to
ingratiate himself with the Republican
party because most of the Republican
party at this point is in an
anti-abortion position so you know
Donald Trump said during the campaign
if I win I am going to appoint judges
who who will vote to overturn Roe versus
Wade and what I think he meant by that
was if he won he was going to appoint
judges who would vote to overturn Roe v
Ware yeah I mean I mean and
um he appointed the three the three
justices
um Gorsuch Kavanaugh Barrett
and and they did what was what was
expected of them
um so
um it was not any great you know
like uh prediction of mine it was just
listening and watching what was going on
and that and it was it was predictable
and it's it's so I know you're saying
it's predictable a lot of people on the
right thought it was predictable but why
is it so many people on the left didn't
see that being predictable well I I I
think um you know Roe v Wade was 1973.
um there have there were a lot of
um republican nominees since 1973 who
turned out to be
um supportive of Roe v Wade you know
think about it John Paul Stevens
appointed in 1973 by Gerald Ford
Anthony Kennedy and Sandra Day O'Connor
appointed by Ronald Reagan
um David souter appointed by George
Herbert Walker Bush all of whom wound up
being pro-abortion rights on the court
so I think
um there was uh perhaps some uh sense
that well the you know when push comes
to shove the the Trump appointees won't
won't vote to overturn Roe v Wade I
recognized I think correctly that the
politics have really changed that that
abortion uh was so Central to Trump's uh
appeal to the right in his in his
campaign that there was just no way he
was going to point some uh any justices
who would wind up voting for Roe v Wade
so that the it really is about the
evolution of the Republican party that
you know in the 70s and 80s there were a
lot of pro-choice Republicans that is
not the case anymore uh as particularly
of among Republicans who vote in
primaries and and the different that
abortion rights has really become a uh a
party line issue in the way it did it
wasn't in the past and to to kind of
reference the the story paths basically
identifying was it was a CNN panel
hosted by Jim Acosta you're on their
legal analyst a handful of other people
and their play a John Oliver clip and
you were blunt you're saying Rover's
weight is now dead done official this is
in 2019 I believe well yeah it was after
Trump was elected okay whenever it was
but yeah clearly years of this year
years ahead of your time you nailed it
you called your shot
and the way the United States that facts
don't care about your feelings the way
that you said it was so blunt and so to
the point people were shocked on the
panel John Oliver who he references like
um Jeffrey Toom is the kind of guy that
she's going to tell his kid you know not
hey I'm just gonna send my dog out to
pastures like we took him to the park we
shot him in the face he's dead now right
like just blunt so what kind of backlash
did you get from people internally in
your in your world saying tubing how the
hell could you say something like that
it's offensive not really I mean I
didn't get I didn't any get any backlash
I mean one of the things that I think
people don't understand that you know I
I I'm trying to remember I mean I worked
at CNN for 20 years I so I can't you
know account for every day but you know
once you establish that you know what
you're talking about uh people don't
tell you you know I I imagine people
said wow you know that was pretty
definitive you really think that's you
really think that's true and um you know
frankly
one of the things I don't love about
cable news in terms of my own uh my own
experience there is the whole prediction
business I mean it's very nice that you
were focusing on
um a correct prediction that I made but
I made some plenty of wrong predictions
most most prominently and one that I I
have thought about a lot over the years
was that Hillary Clinton was going to
beat Donald Trump in 2016. and ever
since then the fact that I was so wrong
about that has made me very cautious
about counting Trump out at any point in
any in under any circumstances even now
um you know I am very aware of how wrong
I was in 2016. I was a lot of company in
being wrong but that's you know and and
um you know I I just think
um
humility is really called for in turn
terms of political predictions in this
country
and you know and that goes for 2024 as
well so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]